hey joelle what is your level of
frustration
here after this you know obviously
heartbreaking loss i mean you guys said
all season long you're built for the
playoffs
um man it's frustrating it was just uh
another i would say not a lucky year uh
we had a lot of injuries um and then
we missed uh during the playoffs we
missed a big piece in ben
especially defensively uh during the
season
um playing against boston it was a huge
piece especially defending
uh jason uh it was just a
weird season um well we can just
you know all look back and you know have
a lot of regrets
can i just follow up real quickly what
do you think the issue is
with this team i mean do you think it's
the way it's built do you think it's
coaching do you think
it's the bad luck with the injuries all
of the above what would you say the
issue is because you know like brett may
unfortunately think that's a very stupid
question there's no
issue we're good we just didn't win uh
we came out we couldn't make shots
uh the whole series uh
man like it's frustrating uh you know i
felt like everybody played hard
uh we tried uh uh you just shot
it just didn't fall and then at times uh
defense was not good
uh we all tried and uh uh we could have
done more
uh i could have done more but like i
said that was a stupid question there's
no issue
there was a lot of stuff going on and
you just
you know let's go to tim bond temps
for joelle
and obviously the injuries you guys have
had this season but it never seemed like
things were able to click is that the
biggest reason why or was there
something else that
that kind of prevented you guys from
getting to the level that you all
thought you could
we just didn't find our identity um
you know offensively and defensively i'm
part of that like you said
a bunch of injuries you know uh you know
josh missed a couple uh games and then
he came he comes back and then someone
does get hurt and then i had
uh the finger injury and then i come
back and then someone else was out so we
i did a starting five
uh that we had during the season only
played about what 10 50 games together
so and then the pandemic happens and
um i'm not trying to find excuses but it
was just a
bunch of stuff but at the end of the day
uh that's what we got paid for you got
paid for to
come out and play hard and you know
trying to win
the whole thing and we just didn't do
that
i know you said it's a stupid question
but there are people who have already
started to question whether brett should
be back do you think that's fair based
off of the way this year went in terms
of all the injuries you guys had and
everything else
i am the gm i'm not the gm i'm not
i don't make the decisions um all i know
is that
uh we got a great organization a bunch
of great people
uh you know outside of basketball i i
never judge people
based on basketball i judge them based
on
you know i agreed over people and how
bad
uh our people they are and i think you
know in the organization we got
uh amazing people from the management
owners management uh you know staff
uh coaching staff um you know to
security teams to training
staff we we got a great a bunch of great
people